مرحبا سيدتي كيف حالك
أنت تعلم أننا نواصل التسليم
مادة سأكون هذا المساء مع
وزراء الدفاع مع حولها
وزيرنا على وجه التحديد لإكمال
سوف نعلن استراتيجيتنا
أشياء مهمة حول cmpt لدي
في الأيام القليلة المقبلة أخرى
إعلانات لتقديمها ونستمر
لتكثيف عمليات التسليم لدينا
معدات جهودنا التدريبية
وبناءا على
الصيانة أيضا وتساعد على صيانتها
في ظروف التشغيل مع
الجيش الأوكراني كما نفعل نحن
علاوة على ذلك مع جميع حلفائنا
والشركاء الأوروبيون لذلك نحن
يقفون إلى جانبهم دائمًا مع
نفس الأرصدة وفي الدعم الكامل و
كله أعتقد أن التقدم الأول
كن حذرًا لأنه قيد التقدم
وأعتقد أنه يجب علينا قبول كل شيء
سيستغرق الأمر عدة أسابيع أو حتى
عدة شهور
لذا
مرحبا بكم في علامتنا التجارية الجديدة
المتظاهر هو قمرة القيادة المتصلة